in this old video hello welcome to code
Tech and tutorials don't up my video
start yet when I started talking so
start number welcome to go tech
materials my name is Matt today I want
to talk a little bit about how to tell
if someone is actually logical or not
now you might think that this is
actually pretty easy but it's not quite
as easy as it seems
and I just wanna apologize in advance
for all the car noise since I am driving
a lot of my thoughts tend to come to me
while I'm driving so I like doing these
sorts of videos oh there it is okay so
let's talk about this a little bit and I
also want to say a few things before I
dig in and that's you don't have to
agree with me I could be dead wrong on
some of these subjects and some of these
points and also that I'm somewhat just
winging this have a few ideas on top my
head about what I want to talk about but
for the most part I am just riffing and
talking about what kind of what I've
learned over the years
okay so one of the first things that
makes it really obvious to me that
someone is not really on point with
their points
that is
there's no nice way to say this I'm just
gonna come out and say it once again say
again you don't have to agree with me
I'm not looking to get a big argument
started I just want to point out some
things that seem very obvious to me and
maybe they'll help some of you out there
go from there
well the thing is God in religion
oftentimes I see someone makes some kind
of grand point that's very short and
then their whole reason goes back to God
would want it this way God would etc
praise be the Lord it's like
you got to support your argument
is they don't support their argument
have no
supporting thing is just that God God
God will do this it's God's plan God's
plans go with God's plan that doesn't
support your argument that's the whole
problem I don't have anything against
believers in God or whatever
but I do have a lot of problems with
religion I don't think it makes much
sense at all obviously there's something
out there the world's ignore mirth world
the universe is so big that there's got
to be something but really we have no
idea
anyone's guess as good as the next
person's guess as far as I'm concerned
all we really know is that the universe
seems infinite and it's large an
explorer who knows that there's God or
not
given and given the infinite size
there's infinite possibility so you
could in theory say sure there's God but
you still you still can't prove it you
can only fear their eyes and together
unfortunately the problem with all the
religious stuff is it just doesn't add
up it just doesn't make sense the more
you dig in the more you try to learn
more your eyes doesn't really make any
sense and there's a lot of lot of people
that just
it's hard to even explain I've just
known so many people that their whole
thing for winning their point of view or
getting support or whatever maybe is
basically that they're reaching out to
other people who leave you god their
argument is so bad or makes no sense at
all that really the only thing they have
is that they're looking for other people
that faithless or that faithfully
believe in God without question anything
and they get conned into it basically
it's a con-artist game to be like I
really need help looking for other
believers out there or something like
that you know and what do they need help
with was the problem maybe you know the
unique details
like just they expect some other person
that believes in God to kind of come
forward to be like oh I'm a Christian I
should do the right thing and help this
other Christian and that's the whole
thing and
you know maybe that's okay sometimes
maybe you don't need to hear everything
to help someone but where I take issue
with that where it really lacks all
logic is
a lot of times it's a scam
a lot of times that person doesn't help
at all they just are lazy or something
and they don't
and care of themselves like self-control
or general have no generally have no
control over their you know whatever
maybe and they really should work on
bettering themselves rather than looking
for handles no that's just my opinion
once again part this sort of brings me
to my second point
well I generally assume people that
watch my channel are probably more
intelligent than the average kludge
given that you're looking for tutorials
and L twos and trying to better yourself
this is sort of sort of that sort of
channel also this is a bit of a sarcasm
channel so take some of the things I say
with a grain of salt and the only reason
it's a sarcasm channel is because I
accidentally put sarcasm and stuff all
the time it's just my way of
but I'm not always sometimes I'm serious
okay so the second point you can tell
that someone has really no logical
thinking ability or completely lacks an
argument but still wants to win with the
argument force if
their whole way of proving their point
or getting to their their wind condition
is basically just tearing down the other
person in ways that has nothing to do
with the the actual
say okay let's listen pick some really
simple and arbitrary not good safe so
you go to a restaurant and you order the
fish and whoever you're there with say
your friend
doesn't like fish so
for some reason they decide they really
don't want you to eat fish which makes
no sense of course it's me what do you
fishy fish
nothing to do with them really they
might first say oh I'm allergic to fish
thinking that's going to change your
mind but really that makes no sense it's
like well you're not eating why do I
care if you're allergic I like it when
that doesn't work they go well you're
stupid to be a fish and
the logical person would probably leave
probably just leave
the first thing game because they're so
down but
so the point is they go to arguments
that really have nothing to do with fish
like they personally don't like it so
they want to bash anybody who does
there's a lot of people like this so
common it's it's just crazy how common
this is and if I were you I'd get away
from anyone who's tech doing that
make your life worse pretty much
they just make no sense they like
tearing people down maybe they had a
terrible childhood who knows whatever
they got their own problems it's not
your obligation to fix it
if it is a friend and someone you
respect it might be a good idea to say
something like you know just call them
out just say hey that makes no sense
what are you doing you're trying to make
me feel bad for eating something I'm
like oh and by the way as far as we know
fish oil is good for you the brain it
makes you smarter so even your terrible
argument of your student for eating fish
makes even less sense now so you know
it's probably best to just call people
out like that and if they don't get it
or if they get mad you know you know
you're not obligated to stick around or
some random first ending
take their abuse
so I guess that's it if you are talking
to someone about something and basically
they go to
they just go to abuse they their way of
when in dark meat is to have abuse the
opposer in some way
that just shows that they really have no
logical ability and that there are
relatively uses in that department
that's really all I got really all I got
is those two points
everything else does coming to mind
seems to be fine like you know most
people actually go look at the subject
or talk about the subject or just don't
say anything and you know that's all
fine but when you go to you know there's
things that really don't add up before
the argument that's that's it those are
the big two that I see very very
frequently the whole
argument oh well god it's like how that
doesn't prove anything
and then abusing the person your
argument you see that side rant
side Brandon coming see this with Trump
you notice that when Trump 2016 back in
2016 when Trump was like going for
election a lot of times he didn't even
have a counter to whatever other people
was saying he would but he just
basically calls people out and bashes
them and that kind of shows that he
lacks logical sense
I'm not I'm not like a Trump hate or
anything I'm just kind of calling it as
I see it I really don't care my person I
don't care what most people do I got my
own life I care about my family and
people around me itself I don't want
people to think that I'm a
whoever hater I try but I don't prefer
to hate anyone but I do see very
frequently not very sometimes that it is
best to go separate ways and you know
you really just can't be afraid to call
people out do it tactically though don't
be a don't be a complete jerk if you can
avoid it that's just a random tip
I'm sort of you know a whole lot of
other thoughts are coming into my mind
about this topic now and I'm just not
going to go there
thank you for watching my video
feel free to leave a comment below let
me know what you think also please don't
forget to like this video if you enjoyed
it I would love to hear more discussion
on the subject I know it's kind of a
deep and difficult subject but I think
it's important we really you know in
this day and age we really need to be
logical so we can actually solve the
problems in our world and in our lives
it's just going about it in some non
sensible way it doesn't do anyone any
good
thank you again peace at all